[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 12 mars bienvenue
dans cette édition du 7 8 journal sur tv
et 78 de 26 minutes pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale tout de suite les
titres c'était à fin février un million
de litres de pétrole déversés dans des
champs et cours d'eau aotulia et vic
conséquence de la rupture du pipeline
d'ile-de-france de total et depuis le
groupe s'affaire à remettre en état les
terres agricoles touchées reportage au
sein de ce chantier de dépollution à la
visite de christophe castaner ce matin
dans les yvelines le ministre de
l'intérieur était à vélizy villacoublay
pour la cérémonie de translation du
drapeau des crs est l'occasion pour le
premier flic de france de réaffirmer son
soutien aux forces de l'ordre en plein
contexte de mobilisation des gilets
jaunes et puis direction l'aérodrome de
toussus le noble une école implantée sur
place à l'accueil des étudiants chaque
année pour les former au pilotage sur
une trentaine d'appareils entretien à
retrouver à la fin de ce journal
invité également tout à l'heure malika
ça qui est brice voir un conseiller
municipaux de plaisir la ville qui se
mobilisent cette semaine à l'occasion de
sa semaine de l'égalité femmes hommes
deux semaines après la fuite
d'hydrocarbures sur la commune d'auteuil
est les équipes se pressent pour
dépolluer le site plusieurs zones sont
concernées des chants et des cours d'eau
le chantier devrait durer reportage sur
place de nicolas landry ils sont
installés ici pour plusieurs mois les
équipes de dépollution sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour nettoyer le lieu de
l'incident plusieurs champs agricoles
ont été touchés par l'écoulement des 900
mètres cubes de pétrole derrière nous
avons des erreurs qui sont en train de
pomper les arrivées de rocard beurre qui
sont collectés par les drones et dans
les piscines que nous avons creusé dans
des tranchées avec la phase de nettoyage
les équipes se penche aussi sur le pipe
line
après avoir extrait est mis sous scellés
pour l'anc est le morceau à l'origine de
la fuite
la réparation a commencé ainsi que la
dépollution des terres les gens là où
ceux qui sont près de la fuite
sont pollués c'est là bas qu'on va
devoir excavés c'est à dire retirer les
terres et les déposer à côté sur un
liner et les envoyer ensuite en
dépollution et comme le traitement va
prendre du temps
nous on viendra avec les terres de
substitution et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
déjà des discussions avec la chambre
d'agriculture avec ses agriculteurs pour
connaître quelles sont les
caractéristiques que vous avez dans ce
hall qu'on vous donne les mêmes termes
le chantier s'organisent en
collaboration avec les différentes
parties prenantes notamment les élus
locaux
nous avons pris un arrêté également de
l'interdiction de se servir des puits
pour l'instant c'est un arrêté près par
précaution une précaution prise aussi à
vic sur ce bassin à l'entrée du village
les hydrocarbures sont concentrées grâce
à la vanne guillotine pour faciliter le
travail de nettoyage et éviter
l'extension de la pollution facilité
depuis le champ par le système de
drainage le champ été drainés donc ce
sont des petits tuyaux qui sont dans le
sol qui sont ensuite renvoyés vers le
rue d'habitude ce sont des raisons de
drains qui permettent aux agriculteurs
de ne pas avoir trop d'eau dans leur
chambre
la stratégie dans laquelle on s'inscrit
c'est vraiment d'enlever les
accumulations de colomb restant libre
donc en surface que l'on peut récupérer
collecter aisément pour libérer au
maximum le mans
dupont lyon et d'installer régulièrement
des points de contrôle la durée de
l'ensemble des travaux est estimé entre
6 et 8 mois
un calendrier qui pourraient être
affinée total s'engage à indemniser les
personnes impactées et à réhabiliter les
zones des chantiers après des ennuis
judiciaires au japon carlos ghosn dans
le viseur de la justice française le
procureur de la république de nanterre
ouvre une enquête contre l'ex pdg de
renault une procédure sur le financement
de son mariage au château de versailles
en 2016 carlos ghosn est soupçonné
d'avoir bénéficié à trith à titre
personnel d'un avantage en nature dans
le cadre d'une convention de mécénat
entre renault et le château de
versailles il a obtenu la location du
site et du grand trianon une prestation
d'une valeur de 50 mille euros renault a
découvert l'existence de cette
prestation après des investigations
menées en interne suite à l'arrestation
du dirigeant
au japon le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner était dans les
yvelines ce matin sur le site de la
direction zonale des crs paris à vélizy
la participé à la cérémonie de
translation du drapeau l'occasion
également de rendre hommage à ses
fonctionnaires oridion 11 revue des
troupes pour le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner et son secrétaire
d'état laurent nunez ses fonctionnaires
font partie d'un corps spécialisé de la
police nationale les crs tous les ans la
direction zonale des crs paris basé à
vélizy villacoublay accueille la
cérémonie de translation du drapeau
cette année c'est la zone sud est qui a
passé le drapeau à la zone est
[Musique]
christophe castaner on a également
profité pour réaffirmer son soutien aux
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
en première ligne ces dernières semaines
avec le mouvement des gilet jaune
nous avons souhaité être là tous les
deux pour être aux côtés aux côtés des
crs crs qui sont sur le terrain du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre qui sont là pour
protéger les français
j'ai souhaité aussi porter ce message
d'exigence ce message d'exigence
vis-à-vis d'un comportement qui ne doit
rien céder à l'éthique
le ministre de l'intérieur a remis des
médailles pour acte de courage et de
dévouement
avec un budget de la police nationale en
hausse en 2010 9 christophe castaner a
également évoqué des mesures à venir
notamment pour les 600 fonctionnaires de
vélizy on fait partie intégrante du plan
immobilier que nous avons lancé 900
millions d'euros entre 2018 et 2020 et
vous en verrez les effets ici même à
vélizy ou un nouveau cantonnement de
passage doit être créé ces lieux
permettent de mieux recevoir les
compagnies de passage qui seront plus
nombreuses à vélizy pour les jeux
olympiques en 2024
là les sénateurs les républicains des
yvelines eux aussi étaient en visite sur
le territoire en cycle de rencontres
initiées en novembre par le président de
la chambre gérard larcher après saint
germain en laye les parlementaires
étaient à versailles reportage ils sont
les représentants des collectivités
territoriales le président du sénat
gérard larcher ainsi que les sénateurs
les républicains des yvelines effectué
des visites auprès des élus locaux
cette visite que toute l'équipe nous
faisons les cinq sénateur des yvelines
avec leurs suppléants et nous consacrons
à peu près toutes les cinq semaines
une journée à sur le territoire bien sûr
à la rencontre des élus mais aussi à la
rencontre des réalisations et de la vie
des territoires
vendredi 8 mars le maire de versailles
le rat à montrer les avancées de son
projet de réhabilitation du quartier de
la gare des chantiers c'est très
important pour nous d'abord parce que
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
nous les élus défendent et
essentiellement par le sénat le sénat
c'est l'assemblée qui représente les
élus territoriaux et particulièrement
les mères est aujourd'hui est important
qui est cette voix qui soit opposé au
niveau
nationale parce que dans ces grands
problèmes du moment on sent bien que la
solidité de notre nation elle tient à la
présence de tous ces élus et notamment
je pense aussi des élus municipaux
nouveau siège de nature et découvertes
visite des bâtiments de nexity et
déplacements à travers le jardin des
étangs gaubert la ville de versailles a
présenté son concept de ville nature et
ses réalisations en cours bon c'est
aussi une des manières de valoriser
notre prochaine visite au planning pour
les sénateurs yvelinois au sein des
communes de l'agglomération versailles
grand parc dans le sud de la france
à présent à cannes s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui le mipim 2010 9 c'est le
marché international des professionnels
de l'immobilier 25 mille participants
100 pays représentés saint quentin en
yvelines est sur place pour promouvoir
le territoire et trouver de nouveaux
investisseurs et entreprises
et cette année l'agglomération a choisi
est de mettre en avant leurs une aile un
renouvellement du quartier du centre à
montigny le bretonneux avec des
restructurations et d'immeubles de
bureaux la collectivité va mettre
également en avant lé projet
d'aménagement de la colline d'elancourt
sites olympiques en 2024 le mipim se
déroule jusqu'à vendredi dans
l'actualité aussi le début de l'entrepôt
l'entreprise éphémère aujourd'hui mardi
à saint quentin en yvelines elle s'est
installée dans les anciens locaux du
musée de la ville à montigny le
bretonneux
pendant cette semaine 50 demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée vont travailler
dans cette start-up virtuel ses employés
auront pour mission est de collecter un
maximum d'offres d'emploi sur le marché
cash et non connu dés services publics
l objectif retrouver du travail grâce à
cette expérience en entreprise qui fait
ses preuves déjà sur d'autres
territoires et les propos sont
recueillis par nicolas landry les
cinquante personnes avant d'être
répartis dans cinq services
on va avoir un service prospection donc
prospection en face à face directement
sur les terrains on va les voir les
entreprises un service
prospection mais téléphonique ce qu'on
appelle le call center on va appeler les
entreprises leur demander leurs besoins
en recrutement un service web qui va
saisir toutes les offres détecter un
service rh qui va travailler sur les cv
qui va travailler sur les entretiens et
un service communication qui va faire le
buzz sur le territoire pour se faire
connaître auprès des entreprises
les participants qui travailleront au
sein de cette entreprise éphémère du
lundi au jeudi
quelques jours après la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
plaisir se mobilisent la ville organise
une dîme jusqu'à dimanche une semaine de
l'égalité femmes hommes
expositions ateliers ciné débat au
programme de l'événement et pour en
parler d'eux invités autour de la table
malika ça qui est brice voir un confort
à vous deux alors vous êtes tous les
deux conseillers municipaux en charge du
projet égalité hommes femmes on va en
parler dans un instant pourquoi déjà
proposé une semaine dédiée à l'égalité
femmes-hommes à plaisir
mad men importante qui était portée donc
par notre mère joséphine coleman berger
plus seulement pour promouvoir cette
thématique de l'égalité qu'il te
fondamental pour la ville de plaisir
quels sont les objectifs d'un tel
événement brise voir l'objectif il est
il est d'abord de sensibiliser la
population et c'est simplement une
première étape dans le cadre d'un projet
beaucoup plus grand sur l'égalité femmes
hommes au sein de la commune justement
en parler plaisir une ville où le maire
est une femme joséphine coleman ce
berger qui fait partie à d un maire sur
ce 1 4 femmes en ile-de-france des
données qui viennent d'être publiées par
l'insee
ça veut dire cette thématique femmes
hommes à plaisir il ya d'ailleurs un
projet vous êtes en charge de ce projet
elle a une importance particulière
c'est important puisque c'est une vraie
question
et justement si la question se pose
encore c'est bien parce qu'on n'a pas
apporté les réponses concrètes et
efficaces en termes de politiques
publiques pour pallier justement à ces
inégalités
mais parlez nous de ce projet justement
depuis quand étiez mis en place quels
sont ses objectifs
alors le projet a été lancé en 2010 est
d'abord sur une sensibilisation auprès
des agents
ensuite on arrive sur l'étape la de
sensibilisation à la population avec
cette semaine de l'égalité
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à un
diagnostic aussi auprès de la population
d'ici la fin du semestre et faire un
plan d'action plus globale puisque la
parité par exemple respecté au sein du
conseil municipal de plaisir au sein des
différentes directions des services
tout à fait on a une parité respectée
d'ailleurs on étonné de le faire et au
sein des directions on a un maire qui
est très engagée en tout cas pour que ce
soit respecté au maximum est ce que vous
me disiez tout à l'heure en off c'est
que le projet c'est d'être une ville
modèle sur le sur cette thématique de
l'égalité femmes hommes
c'est ça aussi le l'objectif c'est
effectivement un des objectifs cirque on
parle d'égalité femmes hommes au teint
au niveau d'une commune mais je pense
que cette problématique
elle va au delà d'une commune elle
s'applique aux intercommunalités et que
ce soit dans le milieu politique mais
aussi dans le milieu professionnel alors
sur le programme de cette semaine de
l'égalité femmes hommes elle a débuté
d'ailleurs hier avec un tournoi mixte
d'ultimate est ce que les participants
étaient au rendez vous pour le début de
ce rendez vous oui vous avez derrière le
programme qui est ici d'accord on peut
retrouver également sur le site internet
de la ville de plaisir se fichent
tout à fait donc effectivement ça a
commencé par un tournoi mais il ya
d'autres réactions qui vont être
justement mener les actions multiples du
sport à l'image de ce tournoi d un ciné
débat il ya aussi des ateliers c'est ça
qui une pluralité finalement de
d'événements position aussi l'idée c'est
justement de casser les stéréotypes et
les images qu'on pourrait avoir sur les
genres et c'est aussi d'inviter les
plaisirs oies et la population à avoir
un débat sur cette question de la parité
qui est une question fondamentale et
sociétal importante brise warin oui
effectivement sûr je voulais revenir sur
la partie exposition on a deux
expositions notamment une qui dure une
vraiment sur la semaine une autre qui
est sur le mois celle dont je voudrais
parler c'est l'exposition héroïne ou
très souvent on a dans les bd des
héroïnes qui sont plutôt masculin là
l'objectif c'est aussi de mettre en
avant des héroïnes féminines pour donner
un peu des modèles
au niveau des jeunes filles et des fils
est en général vous disiez casser les
stéréotypes ya d'ailleurs un atelier
danse qui s'adresse à opérer et à
l'enfant c'est à dire que dire que la
danse n'est pas que pour les filles ça
c'est aussi dans cette idée de casser
les stéréotypes exactement qui est aussi
un aspect éducatif et pédagogique aussi
important est ce la vie de plaisirs veut
promouvoir cet aspect là donc la
question des stéréotypes abordé celui
aussi de la place de la femme dans le
monde de l'entreprise notamment avec une
projection projection du film numéro
unsa sera là dimanche c'est ça clôturera
cette semaine de l'égalité femmes hommes
un film où on suit les aventures voilà
d'une femme dans le monde de
l'entreprise dans le monde des grands
groupes puisque son objectif c'est de
devenir dirigeante d'un grand groupe du
cac 40
l'objectif de ce cette projection et qui
sera suivie d'un débat notamment avec
madame le maire de plaisir vos problèmes
berger c'est de montrer un peu ce qui
peut se passer dans les gros groupes en
terme de plafonds vert j'en profite par
rapport à ceux ci n'est de bae pour
revenir sur le projet plus globalement
on est en train de travailler avec
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines sur ce projet est une des
intervenantes de dimanche sera la
référente
égalité des chances de l'université de
51 au niveau c'est fini je précise de
tonie marshall et qui sera projeté au
théâtre robert manuel dimanche on peut
retrouver je leur précise tout le
programme sur le site internet de la
ville de plaisir merci à vous d'être
passé en plateau malika ça qui brille
savoir un tous les deux conseils
municipaux de cette ville de plaisir en
charge du projet de l'égalité femmes
hommes
les réserves de sang sont faibles
établissement français du sang a lancé
la semaine dernière une alerte aux dont
les besoins sont constants les produits
sanguins honteux une faible durée de vie
cet après midi une collecte était
organisée au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur place
marie l'ania petit fils depuis ses 18
ans patricia dans son sang régulièrement
en tant que femme elle peut le faire
tous les quatre mois
vous vous demandez combien je pas
demandés 480
ses habitudes c'est une question de
solidarité
aussi je pense je lui ai dit que si un
jour j'en ai besoin je serais bien
content d'avoir du sang logiquement
qu'il faut donner ce mardi après-midi
ils étaient nombreux à venir à la
collecte mobile au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
enregistrement une visite médicale pour
s'assurer de ne pas avoir de contre
indications et l'on accède aux
prélèvements je pense que c'est je
trouve que c'est un geste citoyen qui
t'a qui est important une dizaine de
minutes de prélèvement avant le passage
à la collation primordial pour une bonne
réhydratation suis arrivé à 14 heures je
pense qu'il doit pas être trois heures
et ce quasiment fini donc ça prend une
petite heure au plus avec les vacances
scolaires l'épidémie de grippe et les
mobilisations du samedi
l'établissement français de sang est en
manque de dons par exemple les vacances
en avril et mai avec les ponts sont des
moments difficiles donc on doit déjà
anticipé mais naturellement ses besoins
dans les événements besoin de 1700 dons
par jour prochaine collecte dans
l'agglomération le samedi 23 mars à
villepreux direction à présent
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble qui
compte en son sein une école de pilotage
ashton fly créée en 2003 cette
entreprise privée pendant quelques mois
est des étudiants venus de toute la
france découverte avec mélanie poké et
michael et demie d'or
[Musique]
bienvenue à l'école ashton fly basée à
toussus-le-noble chaque année une
centaine d'étudiants sont formés au
pilotage à présentation pour connaître
l'école sous toutes ses coutures je suis
avec le directeur fenech frédéric depuis
quand été créé l'école bonjour à l'école
a été créé en 2003 sous le nom d'air et
compagnie et cette école donc a évolué
de 2003 jusqu'en 2014 pour devenir
ashton fly où elle est devenue la
première école de pilotage privé en
france est aujourd'hui en 2019 nous
continuons à assurer cette position de
leader par un nombre de formations
professionnelles et privées très
important justement quelles sont les
formations vous proposer ici alors
majoritairement les formations que nous
proposons sont des formations qui permet
devenir pilote professionnel
quand on dit pilote professionnel c'est
avoir la capacité après l'obtention de
sa licence de devenir pilote dans une
compagnie aérienne dans une compagnie
d'affaires ou de devenir instructeur
dans une école comme chasseur fly le
deuxième type de formation qui est
proposé ce sont les brevets de pilote
privé qui permettent pour du loisir de
louer des avions et de partir en
villégiature se faire plaisir quand le
temps le permet c'est quand l'envié
présentes et les formations sont très
rapides 1 18 mois alors effectivement
une formation professionnelle dure au
minimum 18 mois je dis bien au minimum
parce que c'est un investissement fort
de la part de l'élève qui va être en
deux étapes une étape de 9 mois qui
concerne la partie théorique et une
étape de 9 mois qui concerne la partie
pratique durant ce cursus de 18 mois
toute la formation est dispensée chez
aston fly à toussus le noble et seuls
deux semaines sont réalisées à
l'étranger en partenariat avec une
société qui s'appelle simtek pour faire
un module de travail en équipage
dix-huit mois c'est pas trop court alors
18 mois c'est intensif ce n'est pas trop
court il faut bien comprendre que ce
sont des formations professionnelles
donc pendant ce cursus de 18 mois les
neuf premiers mois il y a à peu près une
semaine de congés seulement qui est
prévu et l'activité des élèves se fait
du lundi au vendredi exclusivement le
prix de l'école le prix de cette
formation professionnelle aujourd'hui
aston fly le propose à 105 1500 euros
c'est le prix du marché actuellement
pour des écoles de notre notoriété et de
la taille de nos infrastructures
actuelles et l'objectif des cinq failles
c'est quoi c'est de grandir encore plus
alors nous avons une prévision de
croissance de telle manière que nous
soyons en mesure de former 120 élèves
théorique à l'année + 120 élèves
pratique uniquement pour cette formation
professionnelle actuellement sur 2019
nous sommes nous ne sommes qu'à 90
élèves et donc c'est une croissance
quand même de 33% qui va encore
s'organiser sur l'année 2020 de nombreux
cours sont donnés en anglais comme on a
pu le voir lors de la conférence
pourquoi alors ce ne sont pas de
nombreux cours tous les cours sont
donnés en anglais tout simplement
pourquoi parce que ses pilotes auront
vocation lorsqu'ils auront leur licence
à rentrer dans des compagnies ou la
langue naturelle d'emploi et l'anglais
et dont nous avons fait le challenge le
pari que si nos élèves veulent réussir
nous devons leur maître les meilleures
installations et les meilleurs niveaux
d'apprentissage disponibles dès le
premier jour est donc tout est en
anglais
les livres les professeurs parlent
anglais ils auront durant leur formation
un taux etc qui leur sera proposé en
plus des diplômes nécessaires qui
doivent passer et où est ce qu'ils
trouvent un emploi après alors
actuellement la licence qui va leur être
délivrée suite à la réussite à leur
examen théorique et pratique va leur
permettre de travailler dans 89% des
compagnies du monde mondial 1
la licence et asa et la licence la mieux
répandu en termes de qualité c'est la
plus difficile et c'est celle qui permet
quand vous l'avez de pouvoir aller
parcourir le monde
sans aucune difficulté merci beaucoup
frédéric on va maintenant rencontrer à
des élèves
[Musique]
je suis maintenant avec l'un des élèves
de l'école nicolas nicolas alors
pourquoi vous êtes lancés dans cette
filière alors je me suis lancé dans
cette filière principalement parce que
2-1 l'aviation c'était ma passion depuis
tout petit j'ai commencé l'aéronautique
à 18 ans par lui-même et au fil des
années bon j'ai fait une formation
commerciale initialement j'ai travaillé
pendant deux à trois ans et ensuite je
me suis dit que c'était le bon moment
pour me lancer en tant que pilote
commercial dans les rucks qu'est-ce qui
a fait que vous avez choisi cette école
plutôt qu'une autre en sachant que cette
école et privé tout à fait donc l'école
est privé ce qui a déterminé mon choix
c'est que de 1 gbit sur paris donc
c'était une école qui était proche de
paris et en termes d'investissement
c'est soit sur les avions les avions
étaient propres
la fondation est bien entretenu alors
les cours sont en anglais c'est assez
intensif
comment on fait pour réussir son diplôme
ici alors beaucoup de travail c'est le
maître mot c'est beaucoup de travail
la formation théorique dure neuf mois en
anglais et oui ça demande beaucoup de
ressources à la fois pour bien entendu
si on n'est pas natif de l'anglais
s'habituer à ça parce que c'est pas non
plus inné de tout de suite comprendre
comprendre l'anglais et surtout que
c'est très technique
donc voilà ça demande un investissement
à la fois en cours également après les
cours
[Musique]
et maintenant je suis avec pauline qui
n'a pas encore terminé ses études il lui
reste trois mois c'est tout à fait ça il
me reste cinq certificats à passer sur
donc normalement fort mais je pourrais
débuté la formation pratique en fait la
formation théorique durant neuf mois
donc c'est par phases de trois mois donc
trois mois de cours pour à peu près cinq
certificats une semaine d'examens et
c'est reparti pour trois mois de cours
une semaine d'examen pour les courses
avarie on peut aussi bien avoir une
semaine du lundi au samedi et on peut
avoir deux jours de cours par semaine
et qu'est ce qui donne envie justement
de se lancer dans un métier comme celui
là vous par exemple moi c'est grâce à
mes deux grands pères à mon père qui
sont dans ce milieu là j'ai toujours
baigné dedans et j'ai toujours voulu en
faire ma vie et depuis tout petit donc
aujourd'hui j'essaye de réaliser mon
rêve est aussi un but le but d'une vie
il ne vous reste plus que quelques mois
à tenir merci beaucoup pauline pour se
perfectionner les élèves peuvent
utiliser une trentaine d'appareils donc
ça permet d'avoir un bon turnover est
donc assurée à l'élève une formation en
continu la formation est fait sur des
avions de dernière génération et
et actuellement les compagnies demandent
des formations sur ce type d'avion avec
ce type d'écran la prochaine rentrée est
programmée au mois de juin à si vous
voulez plus d'informations une journée
portes ouvertes est organisée le 16 mars
prochain ici à toussus le noble
[Musique]
allez on clôture ce journal avec vous
mais l'ani poquet bonsoir et le 20 mars
c'est le printemps mais à saint quentin
en yvelines il a pris un peu d'avancé
grâce à la poésie le cet événement est
au coeur de votre couture culture et je
vous donne un petit coup de programme
qui va arriver très très vite parce que
le printemps de la poésie il commence
dès ce mercredi 13 mars avec un atelier
à la médiathèque du cannet lille gaudin
bien connu des saint quentinois
puisqu'il s'est occupée des
insurrections poétique ce qu'on voit à
l'image mais demain et proposera avec
olive et journaux des lectures des jeux
d'écriture et de la musique
mais pour cette 21e édition le thème
c'est la beauté et oui c'est le thème
national qui a été décidée jacques
fournier le directeur d exonérer
politique nous en dit un mot sur la
déclinaison saint-quentinoise très
personnel la beauté est alors que faire
de ça et donc on l'a décliné mais en
même temps c'est un thème qui n'en est
pas un on se moque un peu
on emprunte tous les chemins qu'on peut
emprunter qu'on veut emprunter sur ce
territoire pour faire en sorte que la
poésie qu'elle évoque ou non la beauté
soit présenté au public est alors
pendant ce printemps il y aura des bals
des expositions mais aussi des rendez
vous plus étonnant les poètes vont vous
inviter à faire des marches comme celles
au départ de magny les hameaux c'est
samedi 7 mars mais aussi une sieste vous
avez bien entendu grégory en deux comme
en 2018 les artistes vont se succéder
durant trois heures en mêlant note
emoze en douceur avec un idéal toucher
le plus grand nombre de personnes
écoutez on essaye on essaye de faire en
sorte que tout le monde se sente un jour
ou l'autre concernés par la poésie
moi c'est mon cheval de bataille depuis
depuis quelques décennies quand même
maintenant et je suis moi persuadé qu'on
a tous quelque chose à voir avec la
poésie à un moment ou un autre de notre
vie même si
le but n'est pas d'attirer des centaines
de milliers de personnes à venir écouter
un poète devant son micro
alors il y aura aussi une grande
première les 30 et 31 mars prochain il y
aura le village des mots à la
commanderie des performances dansées des
causeries sur le langage et une dictée
vous pouvez commencer à réviser
merci mélanie on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants la présentation de
votre émission le 7-8 culture c'est la
fin de ce journal une édition à
consulter à nouveau sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]